okay you guys want to see what he looks
like see told you he's 165 that's Middle
America right definit looks like he was
punched three
questions we want to say thank you so
much to our sponsor Skylight calendar
the Skylight calendar is super easy to
use and set up I know because I did it
yeah it works by syncing events from
your already existing calendars you have
including Google Outlook and apple
calendars you can also ad events
directly using the touchscreen or with
the free Skylight mobile app and has a
special limited time offer for our
listeners townies can get $15 off your
purchase of a skylight calendar when you
go to Skylight cal.com
DPT to get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight calendar just go to Skylight
cal.com DPT that's Sky L
gtc.com
DPT hey Tes welcome to another episode
of Dum people town you population Del R
Dean Del what's up buddy I didn't get to
sing the dumb people tell Dum
people
people that's the Rock and roller in you
always want and this is who he is as a
person too always wanting to harmonize
with people you always love that I love
it you're like the hardest dude who is
the nicest dude I've ever met I love
that man I I just pushed down the mean
believe me so there is there is a reason
why and we'll get to this later as we
promote you doing like a bunch of
awesome tour dates with Bill Burr we
know you've been on the road with uh
with Mark Marin and you headline
yourself the reason why people want to
bring you these big time people on the
road is number one you can handle big
audiences you're so funny your material
is so funny and you are a great hang
great hang always a great hang I show up
we roll up to The Comedy Store and I see
this guy here I'm like it's going to be
a great night it's just going to be fun
he shares his french fries I don't
understand how you're a french fry
sharer you're a cereal french fry sharer
I don't understand how it couldn't be a
big good hang like we're doing comedy
for a living and here comes some sad
face [__] and you're like what are you
do I was just thinking about this poor
cement when I was at the store last week
CU like if you're a comic who needs
their own space all for it but if you're
a comic who's like angry or whatever
don't come into this space you also need
to stay out there just sit in the car
until you're set and then get back
we'll go get you you stay out there
you're actually up next grumpy face
don't get him he's in the car it's like
you're shitty kid who's in the car get
him get him know let him know the
table's ready let him know the table's
ready I didn't even want him hanging out
with us the we'll get to the story right
now too but that is a dumb people to
story kid refuses to come into dinner
family happy about it that's a dumb
people to story family eat his dinner
exactly he puts car neutral and roll he
puts car in neutral and rolls into the
restaurant you you want to dig into it
story this was sent in by we talk about
practice at not
aame three and guys for the first time
ever you know usually what we like to do
little peek behind the c for everybody
we take the story you take the story you
take your story and we put them into a
doc you know we copy and paste it I've
never experienced this in my years of
doing this show I couldn't copy and
paste from the article so you're going
to I'm going to read it dry I don't I
don't know I don't know why you know
fighting you they're trying to keep us
the forces keep us down you can't keep
it out people town we'll find the link
here's the headline ready yes wife hires
M mistress wife hires mistress to keep
her husband happy says I guarantee
there'll be no fight between you and me
very also very musical headline also wa
wife hires mistress this could be a rock
and roll song keep her husband happy to
keep her husband happy says I guarantee
te there'll be no fight between you and
me is this better than a tie on Father's
Day oh can I yeah slightly another there
another music thing I was in an Uber is
this in Utah no we're going to dig into
that I was in an Uber on a way on my way
to a show the driver you know sometimes
you can tell they care what you hear
sometimes they are in their own music
world sure you guys have the bit uh I
want to rock and rock night every day
you break it down by like being like who
really wants to do that what a prison by
at a certain point in age you just would
start going I it was a day and a half
and I can't I I I rock and rolled an all
party I couldn't party the first day
after the first night ick rock and roll
half of today I can't party all night
long I'm 57 I just want to sleep all day
I literally you guys there's a song out
there I will send it to you I'll get it
to you tties too it's just some guy
barely singing I'm sorry and he's like I
don't want to rock him roll no more and
it's it felt like the spiritual sequel
to yes to the
K I swear to God I will send it to you
you'll be mad that it's in your recent
uh search on Spotify or apple music but
it's just a guy going I don't want to
rock and roll no more that I'm not
embellishing Dan yeah Dan no I can
relate with that
I Miles Davis years old wait so so
that's why you're kind of blue Dan yeah
if I was rewriting the Kiss song for the
age and Stage we are it' be like I want
to sleep all night for one
night and I get up and pee like it
honestly and you're like I just got up
but please leave me alone I want to play
on my phone all
night yeah 11 I want to stare at my
phone all night and not go
out can I just watch this documentary in
peace
okay let me sleep all night okay yeah
here we go yes a thae woman sure has
hired a quote beautiful and educated
mistress to keep her husband happy this
she knows what her Shaman of Bangkok
said she has not been sleeping with her
husband and it makes her feel like a bad
wife oh I'm really interested to see
where you guys will end up on by the way
at the end of this she's saying he has
needs yeah she doesn't want to do I'm
not giving you those needs because you
for some reason don't want to sleep with
me I still want to be in a partnership
of a marriage let me fill that need in
the same way as like do you want me to
get you some sweet tea first of all
that's every marriage one person is not
wanting to [__] go out of it I mean it's
just this is just like I want the
roommate yes still we're great
Partners nobody else I want to push a c
around a grocery store with there are
solution she's coming up with she's not
coming up with problems she's coming up
with Sol she like Cisco Systems she
comes up with Solutions oh I love the
rapper she sent out a video
advertisement seeking young single women
with a college diploma she is offering I
love the diploma is important about it
she is offering pants how much money for
the rooll in dollar in American dollars
I have it in dollars I have it in B
whatever you want monthly or what is it
it is monthly monthly what do you think
what will they pay in this gal this
college educated gal oh wait it's in
Thailand right we got okay I'm gonna say
$250 cuz Thailand you know everything's
that can go a long way 250 bucks what do
you think own dollars okay 80 bucks a
month 80 bucks a month I think like 400
bucks a month 400 bucks a month okay
very proud of one of you she's offering
15,000 bot which is which is
$419 before brand knows how to price
this [__] out I don't want to price out
a mistress if I I mean he been looking I
don't know every time somebody been
around the tie internet tie internet
every time someone's get that right and
under I I do want to take them over to a
wheel to spin every time it's like I
know okay the tie wheel and so the woman
lives at the house oh yeah well oh wow
quote from her in the video is she on
the insurance I want to hire three
Mistresses for my husband three yes
three she said in the video you will get
paid at least 15,000 buck a month that's
4906 get free accommodation and free
meals wow room and board room and board
I want to be that husband this is like a
this is like a like an aair for who
wouldn't be married like forever with
this situation I me Greg Fitz Simmons
had a phenomenal amazing brilliant bit
that like marriages should be like
leases on cars every 10 years every 10
years both can decide if you want to
decide if you want to reup or not if
it's a double reup then you reup if only
one person wants to we're done I would
say even without the lease it's every 10
years good marriages probably are having
some sort of conversation like that
where we at also like you say we that
cuz I'm not the same person who walked
down that synagogue are you no I think
that it's definitely um there should be
in a marriage like a couple lost
weekends a year no no question no ask
going hunting and she's going going to
you're hunting you are hunting and you
know how you know you're still good cuz
you come back that's all you need to
know that you're still good then she can
go too that's what I'm saying absolutely
100% that's how you know she came that's
how you know you're good she came back
yeah so so someone said this once about
marriage that a marriage a long marriage
is actually like 500 marriages so like
oh because of all the people you both
are no over time and what it is through
this year is different what it is next
year for the next 5 years it's this
thing then for 3 years it's this thing
then when your kids are little it's this
thing then you don't have kids or when
they leave the house it becomes this
thing so it's like a bunch of different
oh I you guys will you're you're you're
halfway there you'll know too I think
that I've always imagined that when the
last kid leaves for college or moves out
there must be some day where these
parents now just married couple in this
house look at each other and be like
it's just us so what are we now what
it's just us now we have to talk
yeah what are we we got to relate each
other better get me three Mistresses and
the joke you always make there's no more
emails to read right there was that AC
thing is always did you not read the
email that's what that's what a prove by
the ACDC song I know mistress for
Christmas there you go boom bad it was
so bad mistress all I want for Christmas
is a mistress for Christmas it it was
insane like it is give me a mistress for
Christmas
For Those About to mistress We Salute
You yeah wait so on mistress on some
level I want to be 100% honest here this
couple is might be the most evolved
couple in the world they're so evolved
well there is a dumb part we'll get to
that it's fun dumb but that's what I
love about when we can do stories like
this the dumb kid around everywhere and
sometimes it's just something that would
happen in dumb people Town remember the
old classic Maria banford episode it was
a guy dressed as a a giraffe going and
going around paying people's meters
wasn't there a clown that was waving at
people clown was waving that's a little
I mean this first story is like smart
people oh well hold on I want to hire
three Mistresses for my husband sure as
I said it's like an all pair for her
husband you'll get paid at least 15,000
but you get free meals you get free
accommodation but you need to help me
out two will be hired to help with
document work in my office and another
one will be hired to take care of me my
husband and my child wow so two of these
Mistresses AR two of them are like
employees that she's like I'm not going
to now pay your insurance just nannies
and I mean talk about like where does
sexual harassment in that office have
there's no HR there's no HR yeah she
added I there will be there will be
light filing and
anal that's all both both consensual
both are consensual she added I
guarantee there will be no fight between
you and me now I do believe her but that
is something people say when there will
definitely
F you ever meet someone who's like we're
not going to fist fight tonight you're
like so then other kns will fist fight
it's on the table and you said I don't
want the bread I wasn't even thinking
about we're going to fight quote my
husband has been working hard alone I
bet and I just want him to be happy I
will also have friends to be with at
home Shaman was quoted by saying uh
saying by the meter quote the candidate
should not have a child as it will
become a burden yeah now she's speaking
from her own you don't want these kids
don't have a child that's hilarious and
also don't have a child with my husband
cuz that will be a burn no guarant that
actually turns into like just a full on
what is this you know they have their
own marriage we need to sit down with
the mistress and say are we still doing
this taking place in like Jean said
Provo Thailand this is beginning of a
cult this is the beginning of a cult
absolutely kind of kind of digging it so
far and sex light off yeah have been my
life had I not done comedy what do you
want me to organize your uh your word
processing [__] can you do both
Dan's like can you do WordPress and help
me on my website and then can you press
something else yeah uh my space bar they
have to look presentable and communicate
well she said the woman added that it
was important for the candidates to be
able to quote please my husband well she
said quote his that might be impossible
yeah yes she said or also two things are
going to happen in the story one you're
going to be hey really good for you from
a real place and the other you're going
to go this is a little dumb and they're
not related she said his mistress must
also be able to keep him company and
entertain him so they must have a good
personality and be fun wow that's a lot
but also this is a pretty lame dating
profile it's too generic like if this
was a dating profile you'd be like what
do you what are you what are we really
talking about I think this woman is
asking for too much out of these people
to me it's like just to any woman are
going to show up strange new and he's in
you know me he's like this is fine this
is great also like just let it be
something that he enjoys sexually you
don't want him to be too cool I like 6ot
tall thae women get three of them over
here right and that's it go this is
where you're going to go okay good on
you mopping floors right pathema said
that she is struggling with chronic
depression and that is the reason why
she wants help so I like this agreed
quote I want to find a mistress for my
husband as I am struggling physically I
have chronic depression and I feel like
I can't take care of my husband well
this actually happens to people in like
cancer where they go you need to be Tak
care of you need physical touch you like
I understand that's right that's right I
haven't been sleeping with my husband
and it makes me feel like I'm not a good
wife which is Chad because she probably
is a good you seem like a great wife now
I'm on her side her husband that was the
part you go coming from a great place
her husband pagor dope name that's his
name that's great I I have a pagor
pullover though yeah I see you wear it
all the time they're made out there and
uh what Uhura yes P her husband pagor
was who also feels like he's fighting
dragons on the side right exactly
surprised pagor my favorite roller
coaster in Disneyland
continue was surprised when he found the
ad the ad the advert circulating on
social media so he didn't even because
he had no idea that this was happening
this is where the dumb part goes let me
just read through these ads on social oh
right You' never you've never seen a
more targeted social media ad your life
he sees his name pagor he goes ah
there's more of those names that's like
Mark in Thailand we don't know so he
doesn't even figure it's him right he's
talking to people who are like anyway I
mentioned refrigerator once I keep
getting these asss he's like dude I
jerked off last night and I saw an ad
for Mistresses for me for me don't
believe the iPhone
and bom socks what does he think about
it well he was shocked about it but he's
not against it no love like I'm not
against it I love it you think but I
love this is an outrage no not against
it is the most passive aggressive way no
that's his way of not being he doesn't
want to show that he's too into it
excited look I'm not going to say no
this isn't something I dream about if
it's going to make you more happy I will
take on three m soon as I tell my kid I
love that you're outside playing
basketball by yourself working on your
shot they'll stop doing it right like
I'm not against it right I was against
one but three I guess I guess I can I
guess I can get on board H if it's going
to make me a better partner to you and
it's going to make you happy yes I will
double team this is the dumb part the
guy who finds out his wife wants him to
have three Mistresses that's dumb people
tell when you find out quot my wife told
me she wanted to find somebody to take
care of me this is all quote then W the
woman will be will also be treated like
family and work in our company like
family the husband said he added other
men that wish to be like me should
communicate with their wives about it
they should ask their wives for for
permission so there won't be problems in
the future so this is one of those
things that has to come from the wife
you this you cannot plant the suggestion
even if you are like freaking Inception
even if you can drop it into their dream
and make it feel like they've given it
to
at some point they will find out about
it and it also Jay he is saying you just
got to talk to your wife about it he had
no idea his wife was doing this this is
somebody who was born on third base and
thought they had hit a triple he was
like you just got to get on third base
like I did you just hit hit the ball
dude you never hit the ball your wife
actually hired someone to hit the ball
for you got hit in the head with a pitch
and just wound up on this to me is
somebody who got chosen to do something
and they're successful and they're like
you can be whatever you want to be no
you can't oh yeah you cannot be know
whatever you want to be that [__]
phrase if you don't go through a hard
time you never realize you were lucky
you just thought this happened you can
be whatever you want to be is not true
you cannot be whatever you want to be
like you can't I I could decide I want
to be president I'm never going to be
president you know why no this world is
not going to vote for a Jew regardless
whatever I'm telling you we'll hide it
we'll hide it cannot be whatever you
want to be you can work your ass off to
be something that makes you happy I
would say Target what makes you happy
broaden your scope of what is a
definition of success and then try to
live in that success and find happiness
in it that's something then you might
have sex with three women that's it well
two of them are office workers I was
listening to Rick rub and talked to Jim
Carrey you know and they're just like
you just got to get to this Zen space
and I'm like you're forgetting that the
giant bank account you have it's kind of
full you know how you get to that Zen
space when you're not worrying about St
lot of people million dollar checks to
themselves J car you have so much talent
you also got lucky that you were doing
it when you did it you also you
definitely achieved it but not everyone
has your level of tal Talent Rick Rubin
you got connected with great great
artists who took off and genius genius
like not everyone has those you got
lucky but you and you also got lucky my
question on this job healthare that's
what I said you got heal I mean you are
working for the company she are these
women part of her Healthcare and she
like it hey I'm submitting a receipt
from this m about a 401k on this on
these
GS uh so what he say other talk to your
wives there won't be problems in the
future I never wanted to have any M
mistress but since my wife is offering I
won't reject it appears that the couple
has welcomed the perfect mistress into
their lives I can't wait shamon said
that's the wife asked a uh they're
saying the wife asked a quote beautiful
33-year-old to join the family as her
husband's mistress the woman has become
a close friend of theirs the
applications for the position have
reportedly been closed despite that she
said she wanted three roles so I'm I'm
just looking at your resume here it says
stage fighting under skills I mean how
is that is that going to let's get out
of here on this how old do you think the
wife is the wife the wife you age right
33 yeah I'm going 28 28 is the wife wow
what do you think Jay 46 okay I think
she's 51 all right I think it's like
some freak story where it just like burn
out 28 28 okay okay uh I'm about to tell
after I do we're going to take a break
when we come back I'll do my plugs we'll
find out what Dean is up to but I can
tell you right now that the woman who
wanted three Mistresses settled on one
the husband had no idea let's not also
call what is three Mistresses and people
to do filing and people to help out
around the house and people to help out
the kids right is is Super Nanny super M
should be the new M doubt fires three
Mistresses and a baby three mistress and
a baby would be great movie is 36 years
old I said 51 you said 40 28 28 you got
it you got it there we go all right
that's uh Story number one down the book
we come back with here uh where you can
find Dan and see him and then uh
introduce Gertie also yeah this is
Gertie right here look at this cute
sweet dog you know you know my in my
heart I love me some French Bulldogs
this one is one of my favorites if
you're part of our if you're listening
and you're part of our dumb people
Watchers uh on YouTube you've already
seen this beautiful dog now everybody
audibly knows what a great one all we'll
take a break we'll come back and find
out Dean's got some great stuff coming
up tour stuff so does Daniel and Daniel
on the other side it's D people Town
don't go
[Music]
anywhere people
Town hey guys welcome back to dumb
people Town Daniel how can people
support
you oh my gosh go to Daniel van kirk.com
to see me in Minneapolis at the 10,000
laughs if that hasn't happened yet
otherwise I'll be in Raleigh and akan
and Columbus and Cleveland that's a
hilarities I'm there on a Friday night
little bit of a late show I think we're
doing a 9:30 show on Friday night um and
then I've got all these other dates
while I'm doing yuck Fest in Boston and
just tons of stuff it's all at Daniel
van.com and it's leading up to um shows
in Milwaukee and Lincoln and Cedar
Rapids and Louisville and Roselle
Illinois followed by an 11-11 1111 so if
you want to come to Rochelle you'll see
a little Hometown show you can do that
Daniel van.com 7:00 show is sold out at
this point maybe the 9:00 show is too
the early show for my special taping the
roseold hour is at the Lincoln Lounge on
1111 early shows probably sold out get
that late show come to the after party
afterwards and if you come out to any
shows you can get a Hub City Comedy
shirt afterwards but you can also bring
a dumb people Town headline because I'm
going to start every show the ones that
are mine sometimes if it's a festival
something like that those are a little
bit different but the ones that are mine
I'll come up and I will uh say who what
towy brought a headline for us to talk
about everything is at Daniel vankirk
that gam Dean Del you got great stuff
coming up in November with Bill Burr and
Beyond and then your own stuff let
people know how they can see you Dean
Del ra.com lotss of tour dates uh
Colorado Springs the funny page is
coming up uh Portland Maine uh doing a a
a tour bus run with Bill all the East
Coast we end up at Madison Square Garden
November
10 it's a great spot it's intimate
you're going to love it they run it well
they run it well you've done Stadium or
not stadiums but Arenas correct with
Bill yeah how does that what's the
difference on stage you have to wait a
little bit for the response you have to
slow down I got lucky before I was doing
the first one somebody pulled me aside
and they said hey you got this but uh
just go really slow uh because if you
don't you're going to stomp over all the
laughs cuz you only hear the actual
laughs from like the first 10 rows right
you know that's what you're hearing like
a club and then the rest it it takes a
while so I'm glad somebody told me that
tip because if they didn't I would just
be going on the timing of the guys in
the front row you know so uh some are
incredible some sound amazing like the
LA Forum it just sounds incredible
amazing and some are super whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa so that's crazy you just
figure it out and the entire time I'm
just up there going I wasn't doing
comedy 14 years ago so that's what I
keep telling myself yeah but you know
what you worked at it and you are one of
our favorite Comics to watch you're also
one of our favorite Comics to follow if
we're ever at The Comedy Store hard you
know we talk about this all the time
Comedy Store is hard because there's no
host so no one to clean the pallet when
you're doing it so really you get an
understanding for who is in your
wheelhouse for your comedy by how well
you do after the person is there so if
there's a really and it's not just you
know there are stories of people who
bring Bad Comics out on the road so that
when they go up it's like see how much
better I am than this person which to me
is like terrible it's like a straw man
it's so dumb however I think when
someone is really good and they get the
audience in the right place and then
bring you up we always have great sets
whenever we follow you at The Comedy
Store I just love you guys kill yeah I
think that if you're you're at the store
I remember uh when I first got passed
there were people like I don't like
following such and such and such and
such I'm like well maybe you shouldn't
be passed then yeah cuz you got to
figure out the art of resetting a room
if Rick or Ingram's up doing crowdwork
or if somebody's super loud and wild or
somebody's real low energy it's a great
lesson you just have to figure it out
man it happens on other shows like any
show you're on like festival stuff too
someone comes up and does something
you're like okay I got to clean I got sh
The Edge sketchy yeah get I you really
just have to alter your open like like
meet the audience where they are and
then if you can't alter your open I'd be
like work a little dean.com again I love
you guys love you man and I love you
brought your for the kind words I for I
keep forgetting to do this because we
can't promote stuff so I have a I'm not
promoting a thing but if other people
see a thing that I'm not promoting at
all feel free to share it cuz you guys
can do that thing that I don't have
going on we WOTE it what's going on the
thing I not do doing we're not thing
that didn't happen that's out there okay
good good to know uh I'm glad you
decided not to do that thank you for
mentioning that uh by the way you ready
for this one story number two sing by
Jake grony at Jake grony g r o n i e
love that dude man who calls himself
dolphin Dave I mean I feel like you
probably know three guys unless you live
in Miami you are a freak this is dumb
people tell you want to talk about
wheelhouse of comics being like oh this
is a we're a great grouping with these
people when I say people bring a
headline to the show you and any person
in any audience could have stopped after
Da so I am going to stop right here
we're going to play a game right now
called 8 1983 DJ or Miami about or who
is what's wrong with Dolphin D what do
you think the rest of the headline is
this is my game start again man who
calls himself dolphin
Dave Dean what do you think the rest of
the headline is just take a random guess
this is just a fun stupid thing that
we've never played this game before but
I love this man who calls himself
dolphin Dave sues other dolphin Dave in
County so there are two
dolphin live in the same county and
they're litigious I love it do you do
you know so good I'm not going to sh I'm
not going to shed any direct light on
this there is a comedy community right
now not La there's a comedy community
where two Comics yeah for you know
they're newer but these two guys both
have put the word Chicken in their name
no and they are feuding about who it's a
chicken Feud have their name it's a
chicken
fight know I know one of them and he's a
great dude I do not know the other one
but I I would I I haven't talked to him
about it I would just you know we're not
friends but I know him he's a good dude
buddy of mine and I would just go uh if
you you keep doing good work it'll sort
itself it'll sort itself out here's the
best part about that if I was one of
them I'd be like oh good I don't have to
use that name anymore thank you you can
have it thank you for taking the out cuz
eventually you're right eventually one
or both of you will feel like I'm stuck
to this
namea and if you don't good on you if it
never happens to you then still do good
work and it out I want the other person
who like they should definitely have to
fight they should roast battle it out
okay and the loser of the roast battle
has to switch his name to Sal Manila
okay that would be a great name Sal man
I got finish man who calls himself
dolphin Dave finished the headline
breaks into local aquarium
okay Jay man a man who calls himself
dolphin Dame arrested for exposing
himself on public bus okay I wanted to I
should have said breaks into abandoned
aquarium AB dolphin Dave double d
That's Double D detail R imagine DDR a
loud cocktail party
I AMR DDR is like GNR it's like the all
DDR is introducing yourself with that at
a loud cocktail party yeah Dolph I said
dolphin it's dolphin Dolph and Dave no
it's dolphin Dave do you need to make
Dolph and Dave do something morning with
those uh
lettering DDR comedy then you
get I'm on it are you ready for this
here's the headline jakon send it in you
send it on 3723 okay man who calls
himself dolphin Dave cited for
continuously harassing humpback whale
all right I [__] hate this all right
I hate this of you guys know me in
animal leave the animals alone leave
them alone he's sitting with a beautiful
animal on his laps you know you know how
he feels about you ever any of you ever
closely encountered a wild animal Yes
mine is close mine I guess the one I'm
thinking of the most SE I hate I hate
hunting so you're talking to a I don't
understand why it can't be just as cool
to take a picture you want to see this
picture of this of this [__] that
shoot a
giraffe a giraffe so so how we're at a
point in our virtual world why can't you
have a virtual gun yeah and go out in
the hunting world and then the gun
through the viewfinder you see the the
deer or whatever and you go bang and
then the gun and the gun tells you
whether you hit it or not you get points
for the deer and the deer runs away and
you're done here here's why because the
reason it's called fishing not catching
and and people need to remember it's
called hunting not shooting so I come
from a hunting family things like deer
and stuff I'm okay with because I have
my family and many other families who
shooting a deer provides them with a lot
of meat that they that they don't
talking
about that dick billionaire those guys
trop all trophy I'm [__] done but the
thing is is even for
deer love being outside like the love
the being outside we used to goh sh the
trophy [__] just [__] oh I'm 100% on
I love when those those things like the
elephant Stomp the dude oh you can't
even be Happ and they should love it too
cuz that's the game the game you you you
went out doing something you loved y
exactly and I will say I will say this
is for me the closest is like sea
turtles in Hawaii like I've seen them
and yes it would be so cool the [__]
just touched one but I don't need to I
was this close to you don't don't [__]
with animal I go great white sharks you
know I would cage I got offered to do it
how how long was the boat ride I've done
it twice wait how long was the boat ride
out 18 hours and then how long were you
there 3 days see I've done it twice but
see that's the thing that got me I was
like do I want to be on a boat for three
days that's the only not you know you
just take uh some pills you knock out
and you wake up and you're there you're
like all right but the three days part
yeah but it's oh it's incredible doing
this for three days no it's a super
still on the water it's like real calm
you're just in this uh so you got in the
cage oh yeah many times I've done I want
to do it so bad three times do not be in
a if somebody said hey it's Australia
they're a lot closer it's 18 hours out
we're there for 6 hour for the night and
then we come back I would 100% but you
have to go pretty far for SoCal right
they closed it now it um the government
has shut it down for like 10 years or
something to do some studies so you
can't do it now what did you feel like
the first time you saw the shape coming
towards you and how far were they away
before you could see the show here's the
greatest part uh 340 foot visibility
it's out at the GU Islands that's where
they filmed the uh original King Kong in
the 30s wow so you know when you see
jaws you're like man that is so fake you
know CU it's just going by well what
they don't tell you about a great white
shark is it's so massive it kicks two or
three times down low and then it just
comes by you without even moving because
it's so done the work down there the
work so it's like and then here it comes
and you're like oh the first time you
see it you go oh oh like it's wow how
far down are you 20t 30t no no you're
only down like 10 ft you know I think if
I saw a great w I would just start
crying of the Majesty of I weigh my
whole life to see him so I like a were
you worried were you nervous at all for
your life I wasn't I was just more
adrenaline like this is insane we're
seeing sharks and you know the whole
time you go out there you're like I hope
we see sharks and then there's six of
them around you and by the second day
you're like wow there's like 10 sharks
this is amazing wow and you just start
naming them like here comes Scarface you
know and you get so into it do any of
them Buzz the tower close enough that
you could have touched them oh yeah you
could oh I'll show you some video when
oh my God
that's all right so this is the good
version of this I'm not going to get to
this a man who calls himself dolphin
Dave has been and he calls himself I
hope he goes no cage swimming with great
after he was caught he has been cited by
Hawaii after he's caught repeatedly
harassing a humpback whale and a pot of
dolphins during a snorkeling trip son of
a the incident occurred incident
occurred on a Sunday in March when the
division of conservation resources
enforcement do care I like that name if
you [__] with animals I AG going as
severe as Jason has I'm okay with you D
yeah get a harpoon you can get Haro
should be allowed to be Haro okay with
someone giving you a a a full tank with
5% air in it or or just allow a shark to
rip his legs off and don't do anything
best dose of fent all ever right okay
sure right into the [__] reply
received numerous calls reporting
alleged Wildlife harassment the suspect
and we'll getet how old he is in a
little bit oh I David David Jimenez of
Maui Hawaii who refers himself as
dolphin Dave on social media which
allegedly actively pursuing an
adolescent humpback whale and dolphins
inside of K and I'm not going to this
K Kua Bay hisorical Park Hawaii state
officials said in a statement regarding
the incident doare or doare officers
received a video recording of a man
snorkeling close enough to an analys in
hum pack whale to almost touch the
whale's fin when due care officials
arrived on on the sh early Sunday they
recorded himz actively pursuing a pot of
spinner dolphins they recorded a video
which say her menz was leading a group
chasing the Dolphins so he's leading a
group of people that were chasing
Dolphins by the way Dolphins outrun this
dude oh yeah you know what I mean like
get away from him why is you know leave
him alone can I say this you guys tell
me if I'm super stupid I do believe
there are times dolphins have helped
save people oh yeah I do believe there's
times where even Wales have their level
of intelligence have almost sought out
contact with humans oh yeah well there's
the story of the killer whales who take
you out to like a beached whale or a
whale SI before body's like well it I
think it wanted us to like pet it or you
know or you know obviously get it from a
net if that's the scenario where you're
like this animal is trying to engage
withun then I understand but this sort
of [__] where you're chasing and
pursuing and bothering there was a story
where uh a killer whale was warning this
Surfer like hey there's sharks here and
it went over to him like get out of here
and the guy was like this whale is being
weird so he just got out and then here
comes the great whites he's like well he
was telling me to get out of the wall
crazy whales and dolphins are protected
by state and federal laws thankfully and
humz was subsequently charged with two
violations prohibited acts in regard to
endangered whale species and harassing M
wildlife in a state park so it's even
worse that he's doing it in a state park
it's like do doing a crime in an area
that's going to make it even worse for
this is total dumb people tell in spite
of his legal citations he men has
listened to the authorities uh that he
would not stop he insisted to the
authorities he would not stop swiming
swimming with whales and dolphins quote
this is his quote this what makes you
hate him because it's magical and others
do much worse things that's his thing
this is his reasoning because it's
magical and other people do worse things
I'm not saying other people don't do
worse things there are priests out there
that have done so he's taking trying to
take what ISM to like the even farther
dumb I'm just hanging with them man I'm
not having sex with them that much that
much that much so like if if we
regulated Dum people town you somebody
who visited would be like Why do dolphin
Dave have his foot in a cement bucket
and like well uh Jason ran and Dan made
sure that he couldn't go in the ocean
that's right that's right yeah that's
his foot now that's his foot where that
on his ID dolphin
Dan dolphin Dave dolphin Dave dolphin
Dave also could be if you said that is
David Le Roth now I'd be like maybe I
don't know that he's that crazy he'd be
better than dolphin Daves does sound
like the like burger joint in Ocean
Beach down fish taco place or something
dolphin Daves dolphin Daves I'm going to
Dolphin Daves uh so and we'll get out of
here on this story on this and we'll
come back we'll let people know what we
got going on and Jay will take us home
okay how old is Dolphin Dave you've now
understood he is a person who thinks
that swimming with humpback whales and
with dolphins and chasing them is his
right why because it's magical and other
people do worse stuff yes there no long
hair for anybody else in their mind yes
or I think long hair I bald and long
hair that's I think uh he's definitely
one of those oldtimers 70 like I'm you
don't understand I grew up here this is
these are my animals I'm semi Taran yeah
Dean he also goes I'm basically born
here yeah that answer like well you're
not what good shape I'm in that has
nothing and all this conversation is
while he's driving the Uber all of this
conversation I was born in eity man and
you see the dumbest people there ever I
grew up you know and it's like straight
up Don't Go Near The Bears whatever you
do hey look at this you know I saw a Tik
Tok of a guy doing that to a moose to a
moose he touched the back of the moose
and the Moose tramples him and I'm like
and you hear person going stop it get
away what the angriest animal the fact
that it isn't charged you by now you
already have a good story go tell people
you got with you got to touch a moose I
love it they say don't leave food in
your car signs everywhere in here comes
the the people well they won't smell it
in this cooler and then their vws just
ripped this is why like if we did hit
Last of Us level there are so many
people that would just weed themselves
up I was on a shuttle with bus the woman
just got on the bus started yelling at
the bus driver because he wasn't going
the right place she didn't look she just
thought well this bus is for me I want
to do a comedy series of people who are
zombies having to tell how they got bit
cuz they would just be well I heard a
clanking in a building and that's why I
walked in
it's just because you would just have
all these super dumb people I can swim
with these animals because it's magical
how old is he you say 70 Grizzly Man yep
70 Grizzly Man what do you think yes
Grizzly Man Jesus Christ 46 Jay what do
you think 56 okay get your answers in
Towes you think now we think he's young
and dumb probably okay you think he's a
year younger than Dean all right get
your answers in townies because David
jenez of Maui also known as dolphin Dave
on his Instagram
is 65 years old right we were in the
ballpark you right also I wonder how
many people were rooting for the Maui
fire on dolphin dolphin Dave yeah hey
maybe it'll take this guy out May so
look we have lots of Destruction it's
really bad people's lives are ruined but
it took care of dolphin Dave and like
and if if you are a person ever in your
life like you the the bear saying no
they love me it's just a matter of time
you don't know it is yeah but they love
me man you don't know what they love and
you don't know what they don't didn't
anybody learn from the Australian guy
when he got the [__] Stingray yeah
the uh the crocodile H crocod Hunter
don't [__] with those things man just
don't just like now you can tell if this
dog if this animal loves you it's a
domesticated
animal all last story and R tell uh the
most unhappy meal ever most unhappy meal
ever
r with us we got one more segment don't
[Music]
anywhere hey guys I want to talk about
the new Skylight calendar which is the
greatest thing ever as a person who has
a crazy schedule our schedule is never
the same any week all of us we live
these crazy lives where I'm like even
within your own families all these
different schedules so now I'm doing my
daughter's schedule and my wife's
schedule and all of us are on like
different times you add all these things
into the the Skylight calendar you need
a place that sort of merges all of that
into one we were writing it down before
before we had the Skylight calendar we
were in the dark and now we're in the
not anymore the Skylight calendar is a
smart touchscreen calendar an organizer
for all your chores groceries and to-dos
it automatically syncs all the different
digital calendars and events your family
uses and shows them all together on one
beautiful touchscreen display Skylight
calendar is the best way to give your
family peace of mind to enjoy the things
that matter most so mine is set up it is
sitting in my kitchen on my desk I say
check the calendar now 20 times a day to
everybody so they know when I'm going
out to do stand up what our day is like
nothing is a surprise anymore I I add
the events in through the app which I
got for my phone which is also great but
again it syncs with all your calendars
you can even add it on the touch screen
if you can add on the touch screen which
I've done as well it's super easy to do
my daughter loves it cuz everything's
colorcoded and she looks for her color
that's associated with her name we all
know what's going on now it makes our
life so much easier I think it actually
looks cool sitting on my desk and it
becomes a focal point cuz you pass by it
and you're like what's today what's
tomorrow what's this weekend we now know
it feels great to be organized so here's
we're doing as a special limited time
offer for our listeners you get $15 off
your purchase of a skylight calendar
when you go to Skylight cal.com DPT to
get $15 off your purchase of a skylight
calendar just go to Skylight cal.com DPT
Dan tell them how to spell it oo that
would be SK k y l i g HTC l.com /d
P
around hey guys welcome back to the show
before we get out of here and Jay's
going to take us home let us tell you
quickly just what we have going on suers
scar.com is the where you can find all
probably drop mid October so November
11th 10th 11th we're going to be in
first of all November 6th we're doing
another tag it at Largo which is great
Dean just did it is it such a fun show
and you can feel how fun it is for the
audience oh yeah it's great and also you
know you just just I got a good one from
you guys that turns out Walmart doesn't
[__] with fruit either that's right such
a good one I mean you it since oh you
use it yeah so the joy for me is like
listening to his voice and trying to
write a Dean Del raay joke that's the
trick for us how do we write a Dan Van
Kirk joke for our friends which is so
collaborative it's so much fun we had so
much fun with you then if someone comes
back to us and like oh yeah I use that
it gets a great truthfully so here I'll
give one more example Melissa via Senor
I love her so much she was on the show
I'm like I love her I want to be better
friends with her just because I'm such a
fan of hers and I love her
energy she's so great oh thanks guys and
she we did the show and she loved it and
I'm like okay now we're friends this is
like our way to all be friends so I love
it we're doing one at Largo it's going
to be great Camille Ian Edwards uh was
like giv High Praise he's like these
guys are fast man I would take I would
take a uh tag from them any day
so Ian Edwards us gave us one of the
greatest things told me the and now it's
our biggest laugh flip the phrase is one
of our biggest laughs in entire hour and
he did it in an altruistic manner so
we're doing one on November 6th nober
10th 11th we're going to be at the uh
Blue Room in Springfield Missouri the
12th we're going to do we don't have the
theater set yet but do our two-man show
and then uh we got stuff hilarities in
December and Portland and Seattle in
January and back in Denver Comedy Works
end of uh January beginning of February
Mark Ridley's Comedy Castle probably at
moon tower lots of good stuff super.com
we love you guys support us the ways
that you always do we love seeing you
live Jay let's get into this okay inmate
who escaped oh this is sent in by derang
Jake Smith uh really at Jake grony um
inmate who escaped in akan was caught
after attempting to order $1 burger from
McDonald's so we've now seen a crazy
Manhunt for a crazy inmate you follow
this yeah you're like this
Liv if you are able to escape in a
vehicle or from a vehicle taking you to
prison wear akan yeah I'm going to be an
aan maybe don't show up at McDonald's
like that like that's my thing it's like
if you escape from a prison and then
you're like I'm going to go to this
casino over here dumb McDonald's or
Walmart where your other people are you
know what I mean they're like hey I know
you have meet up after you were you were
in jail with me how'd you get out you
need you need to go you need to go into
like a Morton nobody's going to have any
ideaone that's it that's it so in Escape
he's the Hamburglar he is the Hamburglar
he is uh was taken back into custom
Wednesday morning after he was
recognized attempting to order a
hamburger Jason Lyle Conrad yeah he was
born with a Criminal name three first
names Jason
ly
jlcc baby anyone whose middle name is
Lyall is going to jail at least twice in
his life that's right that's you if your
middle name this is me is Lyall then you
own two lawnmowers and neither of them
work are you down with the jlc yeah you
know black police are afraid of me if
your name is Lyall middle name is Lyall
you've given a switch blade to a
seven-year-old for his birthday that's
right sure and and taking it back if
your middle name is loud you can make a
bong out of anything that's right yeah
right mid name if your middle name is ly
you've definitely started a campfire
where one shouldn't have been
count if your middle name is l you know
how to wear underwear for 5 days if you
use your middle name you're definitely
that's right mid definely going to jail
if your middle name is l you you've got
definitely like tree trimmer like
Clippers in the back of your oh I got
two sets in the back of my yeah uh Jay
he's never your middle name is ly you
were raised by a
boyfriend uh I'll take if your middle is
you we're done Deb but I'm going to take
care I got him what was he in for you're
going to find out uh J who's been on the
Run since Tuesday morning after escaping
from a transport vehicle transfer was
captured by authorities Wednesday
morning following a short foot chase of
course in a this guy never knows when to
stop by the US Marshal for the Northern
District of Ohio short foot chase of
course means he's drunk and he's out of
shape so long foot chase
means around I've never realized in the
years of doing this years how often
think of all the mug shots we've seen go
ahead and think of all the ones you've
seen where it's been a dumb crime or
that you've done this show before we
never have extremely obese people have
you ever noticed that now a lot of
that's due to drug use sure but it's
just it's always either lanky or out of
shape right that odd wry Wy is it we've
never it's never been like your middle
name is the 455 lb man couldn't get it's
never that you know he weighs either a
buck 80 or 225 right that's the first
description we're looking for a wiry
fellow hair parted on the side with a
scar down the left of his ear right that
all comes with the name being Lyall if
you have a scar on the left part of your
ear your name is Lyall Abol that you did
yourself that you made yourself uh he's
now back at Summit County jail but it
was a tip from McDonald's employees that
led to his capture so they know him like
you said he went to his McDonald he went
to his McDonald's and also like like I
thought you were
in that you d
wait I can't believe that McDonald's
employees are aware of anything like
they're sleepwalking through life and
yet they notice this guy and like put it
together I mean if you've ever seen
midday the person working the fryer they
don't got time to recognize anybody I
don't recognize anything when I'm out
I'm not looking are you I'm like amaz
[__] so many I saw you you didn't I was
I was like I don't see [__] I'm in the
Starbucks I couldn't even tell you what
the person looked like one
that would be who I do know I I like to
get VAR how's your shift going when do
you get out of here but beyond that does
not all right according to 911
recordings released by the AC Police
Department employees identified the man
who pulled up in street clothes riding a
bike around what time 4:30 p.m. 4:30
p.m. 2: a.m. 9dd 9:45 p.m. p.m. get your
answers in 8:30 a.m. a.m. they recognize
he wanted breakfast that's what he
dreamed about in jail that getting
breakfast I got to get and I got to
break out of jail before 11: cuz they
stop serving it so he they recognized
him from his tattoos and his limp if you
have a recognizable limp you got to lay
low you got to lay low you can't be
walking drive through it's also could
just be a product of Facebook because if
you do get it enough on Facebook in a
small town they will have all seen it
absolutely tattoos in a limb he
reportedly tried to order a $1 Burger
but was told the restaurant did not
offer those and then he rolled up then
he rolled out he he he got who doesn't
know how to order a burger in McDonald's
who isn't just like give me a hamburger
he's like give me one of those $1
Burgers they who knows how much dude you
got May the last time they offered itoll
do a quick trip you'll get whatever you
want they'll be so nice to you no one
cares that you got out of can I get a
black market baby sure it's rad with a
coffee just 99 cent Burger I do think
McDonald's needs to start selling like
The Fugitive burger for $1 the jlc right
the jlc and you get it fast super fast
keep the hot side hot this so I have two
questions I could show you what he looks
like okay you guys want to see what he
looks like see oh told you he he's 165
that's Middle America right definely
looks like he punched two questions
before we get out of here all right how
old is uh Jay ly Conrad jlc jlc uh first
let's start with that the radster yeah
let me look at it again okay y you look
at the rster one more time dude I think
he's 38 cuz what I love about dudes like
like this is the meth just super ages
him so you look at it and you go that
guy looks 40 but he's 22 I'm going with
22 oh
yeah I think he's mustach 2 I think he's
32 what do you think
Dan 32 is a great guess he's got he's
pierced right here yeah I'm going 22
yeah I like that I going to go 36 years
old okay all right get your answers in
shout out your hand C radios this man
Jayla Conrad 39 years old wow Daniel
last question bonus question going to
get out of here for dumb people Town how
many kids for fun no how many kids has
he abandoned no uh for fun how much does
a McDonald's burger cost right now now
he said he Dan you might know he said di
I was just in Rochelle I'm dialed in on
this all right what do you think well I
know what drink here's the thing with me
I have not ate at McDonald's since they
were a dollar so in the take take a
guess what do you think I'm going to say
you got to remember what Biden's done to
this country $149 do 49 what do you
think Dan maybe in 2006 n I'm going to
go 236 23 say 279 get your answers in
shout at your ham radios thank you Dean
Del Ray for coming on the show D r.com
go follow him go see see him live with B
go see him everywhere support him come
see our taget shows go see Dan special
on 11. yeah a McDonald's hamburger right
now cost
[Applause]
$249 how much would cheese I know proba
27 I just took Rosemary to get a Diet
Coke cuz she wanted a large and it was
a182 she's like it used to be a dollar
I'm like Grandma who
cares I remember when they were a dollar
though they and remember they do the
days where it was 79 cents 69 in colge
in college there was a time in Michigan
and they out of here on this 29 cents
for a burger 39 Cent for a cheeseburger
I would order 10 there you go you know
across the street from the whiskey was
an AM PM and you would get two burgers
for a dollar there and that's how I
lived for years and sneak over to the
nacho cheese and
squirt pums couple pumps pumps pulled
that move a p that couple pumps of the
whz pro tips from a man who's been on
the road de guys love having you here
and uh everybody oh [__] we got to get
back to work
stick around make a sound there's more
[Music]
town